it's still plenty to digest in the
aftermath of a historic day for the
National Football League
a pair of overtime conference
championship games first time that's
ever happened in Peter King was in
Kansas City and after that epic victory
by Tom Brady the 13 play 75-yard Drive
in overtime with three third and tens
converted along the way Peter had the
opportunity to sit down with Tom Brady
and have a conversation what were your
big takeaways from your time with Brady
in the locker room after the game Mike I
can just say this I sat with him for
seven minutes on these little wooden
stools in the visiting locker room and
there was mayhem around us pretty much
it was a jam packed shoulder-to-shoulder
locker room but I sat on the stool right
next to him and what was so interesting
was that I'd say he was as I as I wrote
he was kind of equal parts incredulous
and grateful when when I spoke to him
because I mean at one point he said to
me and I'll quote you know this is hard
for me to imagine nine Super Bowls I
know it's ridiculous and so I mean he
understands that going to nine Super
Bowls in 18 years is absolutely it's
probably something that's never going to
happen again it certainly is something
that he never ever could imagine being
the 199th player picked in 2000 but as
far as this game goes the most
interesting part of this game is what he
told me about the game planning for this
game he told me that they walked into
the players the offensive players walked
into the meeting at 11 o'clock that
morning six and a half hours before the
game at the Western Crown Center hotel a
ballroom there and Josh McDaniels had
eight new plays to add to the game plan
that these guys had to get up and walk
through they ended up running four of
those plays during the game
all four positive yards and so Brady's
point was he said Peter
don't forget continuity when you talk
about what we have done here you know
Ivan fears the running backs coach he's
been there 19 years Dantes carnet with
with every year with with Bill Belichick
Dantes Carnegie a 17 of 19 on the
offensive line Josh McDaniels 15 of 19
quarterback coach and offensive
coordinator that's what allows them to
speak this language when the quarterback
in all the influential coaches have been
together they can change on the fly and
do things that appear to be impossible
to do because they are able to speak the
same language for such a long period of
time yeah I mean that's a great point
and the more comfort there is the more
continuity as you say the easier it is
to figure out these problems figure out
what you need to do spot the tendency
spot the towels in your own game in the
in the opposing teams game and be ready
to go when when it's time to get it done
Brady himself did you get any impression
from him and I got the impression from
reading your column that he does view
this is one of his his best performances
ever six Super Bowl wins potentially
coming against the Rams and what a
bookend that would be he started his
career in his second season winning the
Super Bowl over the Rams 17 years later
here we are with the opportunity for
number six you get any impression any
hint whatsoever that if he would win
number six it would be
see you later forget about playing until
I'm 45 this is the right moment to walk
off the stage I don't think so Mike I
got asked that yesterday on Twitter and
I just can't see it and again I don't
know anything I don't really know Brady
that well I know him pretty well but I
don't he's never even hinted at that to
me and I've never heard him hint that to
anybody the fact is he loves Mike you
would say geez you know there's no
better way to walk off do a Jerome
Bettis do a John Elway but he just isn't
really wired like that
he likes every part of his job he's
gonna love going to see Tom house in the
spring in Los Angeles to work on
throwing mechanics he just absolutely
loves it he's told me five times over
the years that there's nothing that I
like doing better than playing football
why would I volunteer old me this a
couple of years ago
why would I voluntarily leave the game
if I'm still able to play so I don't see
him walking away there's something to be
said though for walking away before it
gets to the point where it's painfully
obvious that you're struggling and there
was a point this year Peter where a lot
of people almost gleefully suggesting
that father time had finally caught up
to him and whacked him over the head
with a giant hourglass and and the the I
think the popular opinion became that
there was an injury that that we didn't
know about and and I can't help but
wonder and and I I don't believe that
the rules require a player to disclose
all injuries to the team if you've got
this side gig with Alex Guerrero well
you can go get treatment on any injury
you have and the team never has a record
of it the team never treats you for it
you handle it all on your own then I
guess that's a legitimate way that's a
loophole when it comes to concealing
injuries but if he had a knee injury it
never showed up on any of the injury
reports and the thinking now is that
that's what went on and now he's healthy
and if he can stay healthy who knows how
long he can continue but at some point
at some point
father time will win and if that's after
he turns 45 and we never find out so be
it
but there's a chance between now and 45
it's gonna happen and the longer he
hangs around the the greater the chance
he's gonna have kind of an ugly sluggish
embarrassing end and and I think that in
hindsight he would say probably would
have been better to walk away when I was
on top I just don't see it and the
reason is that he'll know everybody
you'll know we'll all know and I agree
with you about the injuries you know
remember a couple of years ago when
there was the Giselle concussion thing I
mean Tom Brady is not going to
voluntarily ever say anything about an
injury unless it's
diagnosed by the team it's you know he's
got to get surgery or something like
that he just isn't gonna do that and you
know the team can say basically Tom
Brady parenthesis leg probable you know
and and so and again I don't think that
that is going to be the reason why he
would ever walk away I think he will
walk away when he feels like or when
when Bill Belichick goes and gets Tommy
touchdown from Cal Lutheran and and and
Brady then has an option is he gonna go
play one year for somebody or is he just
gonna retire so I mean I think it's more
likely going to be that Mike that he
will confront the end of his career and
he'll decide what to do
but I just I just think it's still a
couple of years away at least what's
your gut feeling if the Patriots decide
it's over before he decides it's over
would he go play that year or two Joe
Montana style in Kansas City with
another team I think he would and I
think that I think events of this year
may have something to do with it Mike
and I'll tell you what I mean
you know Daniel Jeremiah of NFL Network
put out his first mock draft this week
or last week and he had the Patriots at
whatever number 31 or 30 whatever it is
picking Kyler Murray and that really
struck a chord with me and I'll tell you
why remember last year I forget if it
was Jeremiah it might have been
Jeff Darlington I really forget who was
but on the draft coverage that night may
have been Ian Rapoport I just don't
recall on the draft coverage that night
somebody said that the New England
Patriots earlier that week had spent
time you know with Baker Mayfield and
we're interested in Baker Mayfield and
obviously it didn't matter he got picked
number one overall but that sort of told
me that okay Josh McDaniels here's your
job and whoever is it you know is going
to be the the guy who Belichick in his
department trusts the most tell me about
the quarterbacks this year if they're so
serious last year with Baker Mayfield
what are they going to be this year and
obviously I have no idea who's going to
be left when you get down toward the end
of the first round but the other thing
is the Patriots have stockpiled some
picks haven't they they have extra picks
now in the top three rounds and they
easily could move around and if they
wanted to move up to whatever 18 in the
first round to get whoever whether it be
Kyler Murray or somebody else I think
this is the year where I will not be at
all surprised to see the Patriots take
the air to Tom Brady I mean they've got
to do it they can't do it after he's
gone they have to at least give that guy
a chance to pick up something from Brady
by osmosis
even if Ray D wouldn't be all that
willing to open the vault for the young
quarterback how do you know what my back
to that Mike I think if you asked Jacoby
Brissette maybe it's because Jacoby
Brissette was non-threatening I can't
answer that because it appears though
Jacoby Brissette had a better
relationship with him than Garoppolo did
but I don't know that for sure but you
asked Jacoby burr said and Brady was the
greatest guy in the world to him so I
believe that a new guy coming in maybe
it won't be Alex Smith and to patrick
mahomes here kid I'm gonna help you take
my job next spring you know maybe it
isn't like that but I believe that Brady
would be magnanimous and would be
willing if the kid were humble enough
would be willing to help him I mean
here's the thing if he plans on playing
through age 45 he'd turned 30 turned 45
in August he's got four more years that
he wants to play so he - yeah that's
right that's right
he'll turn 42 in again but again Mike
you you talk you talk like that I agree
with you he might want to play until
he's 45 but if if at age 44 he throws 23
touchdowns and 21 interceptions and he's
26 then
Eagan quarterback rating he's he's gonna
have the hard conversation with Bill
Belichick just my opinion because
Belichick will always do in my opinion I
think what is what's best for the team
overall and again now everything looks
you know swimming everything's wonderful
on the surface but Belichick is gonna
get to that point with Brady at some
point because I think we both feel that
Belichick is gonna coach well into the
future
and if he does that day is probably
going to come and we'll Tom Brady play
elsewhere
I believe if he has an opportunity to
play elsewhere and he really wants to
absolutely would he will not do in my
opinion if he's still healthy what Dan
Marino did when he almost went to
Minnesota but just said there's
something about playing your whole
career with one team I think Brady would
love to play his whole career with one
team but I think if he thinks he still
can play in the Patriots don't want him
he'll go to Team X and you know we
always assumed that above Bill Belichick
at the ownership level Robert Jonathan
Kraft that they that they are committed
to Tom Brady indefinitely but how can
you not look around the league right now
and see what this influx of young
quarterbacks is doing and look at how
Brady was knocked down statistically
relative to the top quarterbacks in the
game this year by these young guys and
not feel like we better get ours while
we can otherwise we're gonna get to a
point where we feel desperate to find a
quarterback and there's gonna be
franchise quarterbacks all throughout
the league and we're not gonna have one
if we just play this out until Tom Brady
leave so I agree with you there's an
urgency to find their young quarterback
who can become a great young quarterback
in the NFL after Tom Brady either walks
away or is not
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports